citation needed joining me today huge
books you know it's Chris Joel or
everybody's favorite Gary runnin Gary
Brannen and standing in for Matt gray
standard mathematician Matt Parker
always clear all before an important
calculation in front of me I've got an
article from Wikipedia and these folks
can't see it every fact they get right
is a point and a ding and the special
prize for protecting good answers which
is and today we are talking about the
flip-flap Railway I is this this is
where the word know if we had an actual
railway tunnel there's a big steam
engine coming down the tunnel with a
word no written on the phone right now
you'll notice that sometimes I have my
hand ready over the ding button here
this is not one of those times
is it a pneumatic railway in the South
of England am i right am I wrong I'm
wrong he's wrong
both flipping and flapping of things
railroads should not do yes
so this is some kind of disaster no it's
it's not a disaster if you got on this
railway expecting normal ride something
something has gone wrong house is like a
metaphorical railway whoa I was gonna go
for like theme park or something but I
like that point what might the flip-flap
railway be is a rollercoaster yes you're
absolutely right is it one of those
scenic railway the nineteenth-century
ones where it would rather than you know
I can AMA rollercoaster now you got all
the bits and bobs underneath expose you
put big panels on and paint like an
Alpine scene so from a distance it would
look like you were riding a train opened
down mountains and there's a guy at the
back who acts as a brake man to stop the
train
the interesting thing about that is no
you have successfully you have
successfully got several things later on
that we were going to talk about without
any questions so yes absolutely
what were those really early roller
coasters called they were they were
tongue 17th century here pushing someone
down a hill yeah yeah they would giant
slightly and all that but they were
giant slides and little first ones we
just park benches going down us those
one in in France somewhere where
literally was a park bench and you kind
of sat on it sideways and then it slid
down a hill and it was terrifyingly
dangerous see the thing is now when we
hear the phrase a park bench we just
think of matin sliding sideways down a
hill on a very poorly fixed wood yes
there was a gravity track in Paris and
you said brakeman this was before that
you stuck on them forever they're just
falling and falling through eternity
like Sisyphus pushing the rock sorry
wrong meeting no his negative attitude
they Center
push you up a hill drop back down the
hill the early ones were called Russian
mount also just meant some Russian
mountains well this is what they
originally were Russian sled rides on
hills Isis so that's where the name came
from
so until the point someone went to
Russia and so a mountain there had ice
in it nobody had had the idea of even
sitting on a cart and riding down a
steep hill not specially constructing an
ice hill 200 feet tall to slide down
I'll grant you that would be difficult
in North then you started getting the
scenic railways now you talk about
brakeman it's done but with a guy at the
back who acts as a brake man and just
puts the brakes on in the right place
rather than any kind of retarding device
that you might have on the wheels like
you would now I'll brilliant so if he
decides to let it all hang out you get a
suit well if he does that on that high
everyone's seeing it let's face it
like it like the break man is the
opposite of a hype man yeah someone
going yeah this guy going I don't know
good steady rocket metalist dead boring
for you yeah you're right he's the fun
killer of the roller-coaster not that
too much fun yeah everybody become there
is also something here in America that
is an early roller coaster that is
called the Mauch Chunk Switchback
railway I bought trust and utterly
distrust that right like I just wanna
imagine like who thought the word chunk
was a good word well that that's the
name of the place where it was this was
a nine mile truck I don't know what it
is but we're going smash crash is it
just some old railway it was one of the
very first permanent railways in America
is he like that bit in Indiana Jones -
yeah praxic yeah I did because this is
1827 so what didn't they have for this
rail power
Harrison Ford just Lucas yeah they
didn't have they didn't have that so
obviously gravity they can get cars down
how do they get the cars back up good
big men shoving up oh yeah close
whoever's on the right next you say ride
ah this this to start off with was just
genuinely a railway to move coal some
people would someone would have managed
to sneak under that yes you're
absolutely right when when there was
downtime people would just sneak onto it
and ride the cars down but how do they
get the cars back up I guess it's not a
loaded car pulls down an empty cars
Mariano levitation horses yes you're
absolutely right mules
yeah but they would send down enough
cars and then they would send down the
mules in the in the car in the car
really not how they felt about you you
know the first time they meant like well
the hell is all this we all would be but
then they'd be like fantastic they'll be
going down the little is and be flapping
in the wind no like that's I think
you've currently misunderstood what it
is to be a mule my friend there's a
bloke halfway down doing a drawing of it
so the combine when they get to the
bottom with us
there's always the smart mule who works
out where the etching guy is they can
make a failure if I Rican people saw the
mules come off going
they look pretty excited I'm having a go
on that and then that is basically what
happened I mean I don't think was the
mules there's people doing this is this
is an exciting ride is that that this is
fun wasted on wheels versus but then so
else went well we can charge for this
when there's not enough coal to move or
mules to play with Oh steady lonely
country town I said that was basically
the world's first roller coaster one of
the mules it goes right in the back -
strangely with a mule in the compartment
sadly that has now been dismantled there
is there is a trail there you can walk
down but I imagine that's not the same
ironically a trail that you could ride a
mule down which is worse for all
concerned
oh you could or you could ride a mule
down on a little wagon with some wheels
oh my god yet wagon wheels they're just
gonna go squeeze yeah the smaller than
they used to be anyway you can't trust a
marshmallow bearing no just overheat
lubricants all well and good up to 50
mile an hour but once you go over that
yeah you looking for a step-mom or later
something fine cut though I don't have a
course ready still get jammed oh
absolutely absolutely
Marmite is that is your quickly it
doesn't get quite the old wall beside
the model uses Branston for breakfast
Matt for God's sake interrupt you've
been going like this for about two
minutes okay I think that I think they
finished oh no there's more they peaked
now no they haven't
but then I realized I was gonna give
actual advice saying use Maltesers as
bearings I'm a desk
this conversation yeah yeah I think
you're actually gonna do yeah
multi-season chocolate finger Maltesers
what's the outer race though Donna I
must have point out for anyone not in
the UK that wagon wheels are a type of
big chocolate brown biscuit so a lawful
wagon yeah if your wagon were about yea
high
no it's more than that yeah so we had
the more chunks which back which is
arguably the first roller coaster
we had the Russian Mountains which could
also be you know early roller coasters
that sort of thing by the point that we
had the flip-flap railway there was this
idea that you might want to get in a car
that careened down a hill what was the
flip flat railway adding to that
flapping flipping it wasn't an early
attempt to do like a loop-de-loop or
something but almost loop-the-loop in
America and they got the shape wrong
were they lured in by the easy appeal of
a nice circle yes tell us some more
about that I didn't think about having a
nice consistent amount of acceleration
on their passengers and they bet they
were either passing out or bleeding from
the eyeballs by the time or both they're
not mutually exclusive
donkeys see I thought I go too slow on
the donkey gets the top but it's tough
on all donkeys at fallout yes yeah
that's exactly where I was going next
because right the amount pushing you out
as you're turning I'm gonna be very
careful here or physics teachers will
email me afterwards it depends on the
rate at which you're curving and so to
stop people from falling out at the top
because the curvature of a circle is
pretty consistent but I mean at the top
you gotta be going bloody fast to have
enough force to keep you in your seat or
the mule and so what you want to
actually do is change the rate at which
your loop is curving to give you extra
force where required and so you don't
have to do it all with speed you can do
with curvature instead where they try to
do it over speed and it didn't end well
yes they they tried I've already given
you biscuits for that but I feel like a
round of applause is required
no no clear the biskits forever the
issues that wins the draw a circle is
two weeks are using it they use an
ellipse to get you over the top very
quickly how many G's work were they
roughly pulling on on this centrifugal
railway as it I anything above where
does it get painful like it must be over
for four I think modern rollercoasters
you can briefly pull about five g's
yes so they were probably tipping seven
or eight and that's gonna be very
uncomfortable yes it actually pulled 12
G's Oh God
not only is it a circular loop it's only
a 25-foot circular loop what was some of
the issues with riding this your hat
would fly off and you would look
ungentlemanly at the end the opposite
because if anything your hat is going to
be quite strong now in fact it came off
on there on the little hill down into it
in it
I know discomfort and neck injuries from
whiplash I wouldn't put discomfort first
in that list discomfort and now I like
this yeah what do they test this with by
the way this is its sea lion park at
Coney Island sea lions no seals irons
okay not donkeys not people not sea
lions another like it in or the
livestock ah monkeys of course sandbags
and monkeys were put down sorry sad max
I'm back those of monkeys in my god
they'll enjoy it the donkeys did
sea lion Park became Luna Park as like
famous names and all that ah but
flip-flap railway was not retained why
not I mean because of its unpopularity
and reputation row I will give you the
it was it was not something you got on a
second time
for one reason or another no one got
into it again you know but there is one
last legendary theme park I want to talk
about is it flamingo London no it is
action Park in New Jersey oh god this
isn't ringing bells and I have
absolutely no idea why oh well why why
might it be legendary vote for folks who
work this is in the 1980s and you killed
a million billion people in their wave
pool or something
I hurt a lot of people so how are you I
will give you the point for it
it was hang on wait your guess was it
killed a million billion people yeah and
you're like close enough to a few people
got a bit injured yeah yeah feel free to
chuck some ideas and and the reason I
mention is in particular to do with all
the other things we've talked about is
that they had the cannonball which is
very similar to a few of the things
we've talked about with one important
difference in a in a summer Park in a
theme park what did they have that was a
loop that they attempted a water based
loop to lose yes they did it was at
their water park how do you do that the
top can be a shower
the thing about water is it follows the
laws of physics yes you are absolutely
right it was a looping waterslide are
not the mods like there are there are a
couple of the modern looping water signs
an interesting kind of curve this was
circle that would take off your clothes
wouldn't it come to join me in the loop
how about we give you out of those weird
things
it would certainly having had a couple
of waterslide incidents shall we say
moments of unpleasantness
no it doesn't take your clothes off
riders were weighed and hosed down with
cold water what I'm then instructed how
to position their bodies to complete the
ride
No I'm already not getting on this oh
you just wanted an excuse to pause let's
be honest here top of the right some
before even you get on the ride you're a
waterpark you hope and I assumed to drop
into a nice warm bath like water at the
end the last thing you want is some boat
with a little you know with a hose pipe
with a little spraying it on the end
going right arms up they sent some test
dummies down first what were the reports
on what happened they didn't come down
in one yes right they were dismembered
on the way down and one person one
unfortunate person the top of the loop
what happened their clothes fell off
trousers caught on a nail just hanging
there in space getting showered on it
was a closed loop they really doing a
lot you know this is the first one
you've described we're still thinking I
want to go on this got stuck at the top
and they had to add a hatch at one point
to remove people who got stuck at the
top and didn't want to go down the other
side wait because yeah cuz you're on
this surface now as you go down you're
gonna have that sheer drop clunk dunk
carry-on yes there had to be extractions
as it put here Wow
which is not great so it's supposed to
get physically stuck as if they were too
large
no they just weren't going fast enough
oh my god
employees were offered a hundred dollars
to test it and I'm gonna quote a hundred
bucks did not buy enough booze to drown
out that memory I'm with my I want to go
on this at the end of the show
congratulations Matt you win this week
you win a brand-new armored fighting
vehicle that is actually an old fighting
vehicle just rebooted to look mom say JJ
Abrams tank Oh
so with that we say thank you
[Music]